[Music]
[Music]
at seven o'clock i'm dermott monahan
this is sky news tonight the top story a
spring statement aimed at easing the
cost of living
the chancellor presents his plan aiming
to offset the pain of rising national
insurance contributions with a lift to
the threshold
my tax plan delivers the biggest net cut
to personal taxes in over a quarter of a
century
help on the four courts as well as fuel
duty is cut by five pets
but labour accused him of making the
wrong choices as households suffer the
highest inflation for three decades
[Music]
a very good evening and welcome to a
special program looking at today's
spring statement when rishi soon sunnag
entered number 11 downing street two
years ago he did so with hopes of
becoming a low tax chancellor while
covert of course soon put paid to that
with soaring public spending and
borrowing and two years on the economic
cost of lockdowns remains and there's a
long way to go now in restoring the
public finances today's mini budget did
however see some concessions a rise in
the national insurance contribution
threshold and a cut to fuel duty but
labour said not enough accusing him of
missing the chance of an energy windfall
tax and opting instead for the wrong tax
at the wrong time in a moment our
economics editor breaks down exactly
what today's announcements mean for
people's pay packets
but first let's take a look at what
those changes are precisely so his first
big announcement was to cut fuel duty by
five pence uh from 6 p.m this evening
until march next year so it's already in
operation homeowners installing heat
pumps insulation and solar panels will
pay no vat for the next five years
although the chancellor stopped short of
cancelling a planned increase in
national insurance contributions he said
he will increase the threshold by 3 000
pounds meaning that employees will be
able to earn 12 570 pounds without
paying any national insurance
and not only did the chancellor announce
partial tax cuts for now but he
announced tax cuts to come income tax
will be reduced from 20 to 19 pence in
the pound by the end of the parliament
in 2024 he said the chancellor also
revised down the uk's gross domestic
product growth forecast for this year to
3.8
saying there is uncertainty about how
much of an impact the conflict in
ukraine will have on the economy
and rishi sunak's statement came after
inflation reached a 30-year high it's
now 6.2 percent in the 12 months to
february putting extra pressure on the
chancellor to help households with
rising living costs our political editor
beth rigby has tonight's top report
a mini budget but this a generational
crisis inflation at a level not seen for
three decades and it's going to get
worse is there more pain to come
chancellor
rishi's son under pressure to meet the
scale of this moment armed with a
statement that for so many will decide
if they can heat their homes and feed
their families
from covid to cost of living the
emergency chancellor promising to step
in again people should know
that we will stand by them as we have
throughout the last two years
today
i can announce
for only the second time in 20 years
fuel duty will be cut
not by one not even by two but by five
pence per liter
[Music]
the biggest cut to all fuel duty rates
ever
a year-long cut on fuel duty labour
bench is unimpressed
but the big reveal still to come easing
the pain on the april national insurance
hike our current plan
is to increase the next threshold this
year
by 300 pounds
but i'm not going to do that mr speaker
i'm going to increase it by the full 3
000 pounds
from this july people will be able to
earn 12
570 pounds a year without paying a
single penny of income tax or national
insurance
and a tax promise from a chancellor
already eyeing the next election
i can confirm
before the end of this parliament in
2024 for the first time in 16 years
the basic rate of income tax will be cut
from 20 to 19 pence in the pound
a tax cut for workers for pensioners for
savers a 5 billion pound tax cut for 30
million people
the opposition clear this simply not
enough inflation is at its highest level
for 30 years and rising
energy prices at record highs
people are worried sick
for all his words it is clear that the
chancellor does not understand the scale
of the challenge exactly
tax cuts always put a spring in the step
of conservative mps but the outlook far
from sunny official figures forecast the
biggest fall in living standards this
year since the 1950s
and minimal help today for the worst off
what the chancellor did today was to
help a little bit for people on um low
to moderate earnings but he did nothing
at all actually for people who are out
of work and dependent on benefits and
they're really perhaps going to find it
the biggest struggle over the next
several months when that next rise in
energy prices comes next one in april
another one
around october i think there will be
more pressure on the chancellor because
there are going to be more
households particularly again the very
poorest who are really going to be
struggling at that point
for all the rhetoric around tax cuts
this mini budget really lived up to name
today this a package of measures that
barely even scratches the surface when
it comes to dealing with the biggest
fall in living standards in over 60
years the chancellor for now is biden
his time in the face of huge economic
uncertainty but one ally did concede to
me tonight that mr sunak is likely to
have to do more in the autumn if not
before
millions of voters are going to feel the
pain of rising prices this year and
petrol only part of our problem and this
mans too
not a crisis of his making but one he'll
be expected to help fix
that's here with me now with more
analysis so beth i mean first of all on
the politics how has it gone down with
the various factions within the
conservative party
well look i think people wanted more
when the chancellor stood up today and
said we stood by people
two years ago over covered and we will
keep standing by them that is not the
feeling that the public have in fact
there's a poll just out from opinion
tonight it's just landed only 27
of the uk public think the spring
statement measures will have a positive
effect on their personal
finances and when you look at what the
chancellor announced
i mean basically he reversed but a sixth
of the tax rises he's implemented in the
past couple of years there was a big
windfall that many conservative mps
wanted him to begin spending this is
because of higher than expected growth
and better than expected tax receipts
the ft estimating that's about 50
billion pounds of additional headroom
the chancellor has he's holding on to
that
now you have to have a little bit of
sympathy from hit for him here why is he
doing it because of the volatility they
don't really know what's going to happen
to energy prices they don't understand
yet how the economic sanctions and the
war in ukraine how long it will go on
for how it will feed into the economic
outlook and so he's keeping his powder
dry he's holding on
to money he's waiting to give himself a
cushion for additional measures but i
would be very surprised if the
chancellor does not have to make further
announcements in the summer or in the
autumn don't forget
energy bills go up the cap rises to 2
000 pounds in april it could go up to 3
000 pounds in october that's another
massive chunk of money that people will
have to find so the pressure is on i
think this was rather light you remember
in covid times when there would be an
economic statement and then a few weeks
later another
i wonder whether we are moving back into
that territory now in the coming months
and the opposition i mean very critical
about the lack of a windfall tax on
energy companies and
and pointing out that there's nothing
there really for people on benefits
people who don't drive cars the very
poorest well that's exactly it and
actually the obr was saying that in
terms of the cost of living squeeze of
2.2
per household these measures today only
really ameliorated a third of that so
two-thirds of it untouched which is what
labour are getting that which is you
haven't got it you need to do
more uh what the chancellor there was
doing as i said i think it's a holding
pattern where he gives himself some
maneuverability look derma i think the
biggest issue of all of this is in 2019
this government promised to level up the
country and they are elected on the back
of brexit and also improving people's
livelihoods and their standards of
living in the way they felt about where
their lives getting better and
ultimately if you get to 2024
and people
are struggling to make ends meet they
are not going to feel
better off so a government that's
promising tax cuts in two years time
they'll say well you didn't keep the
promises of 2019 and i think that's the
biggest challenge for the government in
the coming months to prove to the public
that they can improve their living
standards okay beth thanks for the
analysis beth rigby our political editor
there well as you heard inflation at a
30-year high now a pending lift on the
energy price cap and rises in national
insurance contributions the perfect
storm perhaps as britain faces a cost of
living crisis so how exactly will
today's announcements help and could the
chancellor have done more our data and
economics editor ed conway has his
analysis
this was supposed to just be an update
but in practice there were lots of new
policies and new figures and
particularly striking ones underlining
the state of what we are going to be
going through over the next uh few
months this shows you household
disposable income this is a chart that
just was out from the office budget
responsibility anything above the line
shows we are getting better off and
we're going all the way back now to 1956
and you can see that most of these bars
through the years from the 50s to the
60s to the 70s and 80s and 90s are above
the line we're getting better off and
there's the financial crisis a few years
where it was below the line but just
look at this red bar that's the year
we're going into now and that bar
is the lowest it has ever been the
biggest
fall in our real household disposable
income that we've seen in statistical
records that is what we are confronting
at the moment that's the cost of living
crisis
and the chancellor has managed to make
that bar a little bit less deep than it
would otherwise have been but
nonetheless it is still going to be very
tough indeed how has he made it less
deep well it comes down to money going
out of the treasury how much money is
going out we can see each year if we
look at the total policies and the
impacts you can see there was money
going into the treasury uh in the year
that we're in at the moment but next
year a bit of money going out actually
quite a lot of money 8.4 billion pounds
and then smaller amounts in the future
years it's worth us just breaking down
that money that is going out because
that's what we're talking about here all
of these policies uh that have been
announced by the chancellor and when it
comes to breaking it down there are some
interesting things in fact on top of the
money that's going out and we'll look at
that in a second there was a bit of
extra money coming in student loans
because of a change in the way that
they're calculated students will end up
paying more money in the coming years
and that's banks by the treasury but
then you've got that cash going out
that's helping to finance that change in
the national insurance threshold extra
3000 pounds that you kind of don't have
to pay national insurance on quite a lot
of money fuel duty as well 2.4 billion
pounds not the biggest chunk but
nonetheless pretty big and then that
that's the energy bills uh package that
we had just uh not too long ago from the
chancellor nine billion pounds just over
nine billion pounds but here's the thing
he could have spent more and that's the
big question mark do we see him come
back later when that cost of living
crisis starts to bear down on everyone
and spend a little bit more money the
final thing that's worth saying there
was that tax plan from the chancellor
document underlining how much he wants
to get those taxes down but here's a
chart that wasn't in it this is the tax
burden taxes as a percentage of gdp just
how heavily taxed we are as an economy
again going all the way back through to
history to the post-war period and have
a look at this line it's relatively low
and it kind of hangs around this area
kind of 30s 33 or so percent
but
even when income tax has been cut by a
penny which he plans to do towards the
end of this parliament it's still this
line going to be the highest it's been
since
1949 underlining the fact that though he
wants to be seen as a tax cutting
chancellor the statistics tell a very
different story indeed so those are some
of the data from this big moment for the
chancellor far bigger than most people
expected it's supposed to just be a
spring statement it felt actually a bit
more like a budget
just let you know ed's going to be
joining me at half past this hour along
with our deputy political editor sam
coats to give us an even deeper analysis
of what the chancellor just announced
today
but first the british chambers of
commerce has said today's statement by
the chancellor fell short of what is
needed to support business they called
the cut to fuel duty a drop in the ocean
in the face of the tsunami of surging
costs well in a moment i'll be speaking
to the head of the bcc siobhan havilland
about the impact on british business but
first our correspondent paul kelso has
this report
pulling the trigger at the pump is a
painful business
particularly if your business is driving
it's just getting to a point where is it
worth it anymore it's just well i'm
taking no wages out at the minute i'm
funding
the extra fuel costs
paul has a council contract to transport
disabled children to school but the fuel
price was set in 2019 so he loses money
on every mile even allowing for the 5p
cut in fuel duty announced by the
chancellor no it won't make no
difference whatsoever but every little
helps it'd have to be 20 30 40p
a liter to help save three months ago i
was probably paying one pound seventeen
one pound eighteen a liter now it's gone
up to just locally 182 nearly 183 litre
and obviously 10 vehicles using between
60 and 80 liters a week
becomes expensive keeping production
lines moving has got more expensive too
there's no energy price cap for business
and no new measures to help companies
like this packaging manufacturer
in the modern economy everything from
eggs to engines comes in a box so price
rises here will be delivered to our
doors one way or another energy bills
are around
seven thousand pound a month
we're fixed until mid 2023
that's seven thousand goes to eighteen
thousand and we're one of the lower
energy consumers within the supply chain
with inflation at a thirty 30-year high
of 6.2 percent even before russia
invaded ukraine worse is to come what
makes energy and fuel inflation so
pernicious is it affects the price of
everything from raw materials to
transport even the pallets goods are
loaded on it's almost inevitable
manufacturers have to pass on these
costs to consumers there's very little
the chancellor can do about it
food price inflation may see the
steepest increase of all iceland has 1
000 stores many in the least prosperous
communities the boss says the chancellor
should have done more to insulate his
business and his customers
business is not some endless sponge that
can forever soak this stuff up we talk
rightly about the consumer and i think
that's important but also the government
needs to protect business as well
because ultimately it's the consumer
that pays for it so
what i would have liked to have seen was
a a price cap on energy for business
rebuilding the economy after kobit was
never going to be straight forward
businesses face the hardest year yet
knowing they'll have to stand or fall
alone paul kelso sky news in
staffordshire
let's get more business reaction then
i'm joined by siobhan haviland director
general of the british chambers of
commerce very good evening to you svon
havilland um well um i know you have
welcomed the the cut in fuel duty but uh
not enough
um hi good evening no
really not enough that this was an
opportunity for the chancellor to really
do something for business as you know
businesses have been facing into a
tsunami of costs starting last summer
with an increase in raw material costs
massive increases in shipping costs
we saw uh difficulties in recruitment
and energy prices start to rise last
winter but of course energy prices are
now an
unprecedented level
uh i had a call from one of our
businesses last week um whose energy
prices are going up from 14 000 pounds a
month to 46 000 pounds a month next
month so there's
it there's a real it's a real issue with
with price with costs and we really
wanted to see uh the chance to do
something on possibly
delaying the national insurance
increases or looking at a temporary
energy price cap for small and
medium-sized businesses okay so because
there is no price cap of course for
businesses what kind of level would you
like to see and how would it operate
so
many small businesses buy energy like
consumers do um but of course unlike
consumers they don't have a price cap
nor a rebate system and unlike big
businesses they don't have a a deep
balance sheet uh to to see them through
so
um
we would like to see them look at what
sort of either energy price cap
temporary one or um possibly a rebate
scheme would work you know businesses
welcomed things like the increase of the
employment allowance and as you
referenced earlier the cuts in in fuel
duty
and the and the chancellor did also talk
about
looking at future taxes reforming um
apprenticeships looking at r d credits
and businesses welcome all of those
things but we've got an immediate crunch
uh that needs to be dealt with yeah i
mean the big looming threat out there is
inflation and one imagines then that if
there is no
real help for businesses in dealing with
these rising costs they of course pass
on the costs to the consumer and we get
this inflationary circle
yeah that's that's absolutely right so
we run a quarterly economic survey uh
inflation has been the number one issue
for businesses for the last three
quarters in a row and that is the first
time it's ever been a number one issue
since the survey was started in 1989 you
can see how significant that is and
businesses you know they try to absorb
those costs for as long as possible they
don't want to pass on prices to either
to their supply chain or to consumers
but eventually they have to in our last
survey in february 75 of businesses said
that they were going to have to pass on
those costs and of course that was
before uh what the the events we've seen
in ukraine and presumably business is
then going to have
precious little surplus to invest and
therefore to improve productivity which
we all want to see
yeah yeah i mean
two years of coving meant cash flow and
cash reserves for investment were
already at an all-time low so now
they've got extra cost to absorb it's
going to be really tricky and businesses
will they'll do a number of things so
they'll stop recruiting um and they will
they will pause on investments and we
don't want to see that because what we
want
from the chancellor is uh
control of helping to control those
costs so that businesses can get back to
investing and that get back to growing
because that's what they want to do
driving the economy let me mention
lastly the r word we're always told
let's not talk ourselves into recession
but do you fear one is looming
i think our feedback from our members
has been that
they have been able to absorb a lot of
the on costs while they've seen their
order books looking strong and steady
and i think their worry is that they're
beginning to see a slowdown in those
orders
and uh that obviously leads them to
start thinking about the r word and we
don't want that to happen we want to
avoid that tipping point okay siobhan
havilland uh very good talking to you
thank you very much indeed shawn
havilland there from the british
chambers of commerce and of course
reaction to the chancellor's statement
certain to feature all over tomorrow's
papers we've got our extended press
preview and news review at half past 10
this evening with tonight's news and
tomorrow's headlines joining us will be
the daily mails consultant editor andrew
pearce and the daily mirrors associate
editor kevin mcguire
and you're watching a special program on
the chancellor's spring statement spring
budget so to speak coming up we're going
to be in berry and greater manchester
gauging the reception to today's
announcements
amongst voters
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they'll be killed
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day can't access those and needs
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
i think experiencing the 2 million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches
she born robbins sky news bangkok
[Music]
now then in responding to risi sunak's
statement in the house of commons today
the shadow chancellor accused him of not
understanding the scale of the challenge
facing families rachel reeves pointed
out the lack of changes to universal
credit to help offset rising inflation
despite this mr tsunak claimed that 70
percent of people who pay national
insurance will pay less of it our
correspondent inzamam rasheed has been
in burying greater manchester seeing how
the chancellor's statement went down
with voters
this is what the cost of living crisis
looks like
a choice between feeding your kids
or heating your home
a choice dawn is faced with day in and
day out
the more you're worrying about how am i
going to pay this
um the worse you actually feel
and then announcement like this comes
along and you you feel even worse
and you're worrying even more and
it's a bit of a nightmare
and today that nightmare continued the
chancellor's statement didn't include
anything to benefit those on universal
credit dawn says the 300 pounds a year
she'll save from the national insurance
changes is non-existent
we're paying that out already
or we're going to be from the looks of
it with the amount that fuel and food
and everything's going up and it just
feels like no matter what we're trying
it's
we're not getting anywhere we're not
and we're actually getting worse and
worse
off
thankfully it was a warm spring day at
berry market a welcome start difference
from life at home in the cold a life
irene and lila are used to
they don't put me central east you know
i've been about i think was about 25
quid for this big blanket thing and i
put that on at night just sit under it
you know
do you think the politicians down in
london do you think they understand the
situation
no
go for a meal stephen feels the
politicians listen
but not enough he's thankful to see the
price of fuel drop
but with it at a record high he's
worried it's still too much the concern
is that people come from fire and why to
bury market it's going to cost them to
get here with fuel prices it's going to
cost them all together and then they've
got to pay for your parking and
etc etc it just goes on and on
this is a crisis that will inevitably
hurt the poorest the most but the
suffering will be widespread millions of
households across the country are
bracing themselves to feel the pain when
it deepens next month
in zaman rasheed sky news barry
while you're watching a special program
on the chancellor's spring
statement uh coming up we're in barry no
we're not we've just been there we're
going to be discussing it all with our
economics editor and our deputy
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back you're watching our special
program on the chancellor's spring
statement today in it he raised the
national insurance threshold by three
thousand pounds and announced a cut in
fuel duty by five pence a liter his mini
budget which is what it became
aimed at easing the burden of the cost
of living crisis uh in a moment we'll uh
be speaking to the treasury minister
john glenn but first let's see how
today's announcements will affect
people's pockets i'm joined now by our
economics and data editor ed conway and
our deputy political editor sam coats uh
good to see you both ed let's start with
you and uh overall how much trouble are
we in and is inflation at the heart of
it
yeah i mean inflation is you know the
big story here normally when it comes to
these kinds of events like the spring
statement
we're looking at things like the growth
numbers we're looking at the state of
the economy uh we sometimes focus on
inflation but frankly you know most of
these kind of events talk about it going
to kind of like be as close as possible
to two percent that's the bank of
england's forecast this time around very
different indeed i'll bring up the
inflation numbers so you just get a
sense of that uh and you can kind of see
when you see those inflation numbers
just how serious uh that is there's no
not coming up at the moment i will tell
you um that previously the forecast was
for inflation to be around four percent
you know now the expectation is it's
going to peak uh at about eight percent
or just above eight percent and if that
is indeed the case and then we're
talking about a severe cost of living
crisis and when you look at the impact
of that cost of living crisis on
families pockets well we're talking
about something that we really have
rarely seen before
we're talking about when you look at
real household disposable incomes the
biggest fall that we've seen since the
1950s i mean it is a striking number uh
and one that we've been kind of trying
to digest over the course of the day but
what's doubly striking is the fact that
the chancellor while he has reduced it
somewhat so he's reduced it by about a
third the impact of what we're going to
experience over the course of the next
few months
he could have done more and i think
that's the thing
that he will be
kind of reflecting on over the course of
the next few months as we see more
stories of
many people across the country from all
income levels facing this cost of living
crisis people opening their bills uh
realizing that they are facing a serious
uh crisis on their bills as a result of
that
um and the question mark as to whether
he's got kind of more money left we may
well see him have to come back to the
table he got about 20 billion pounds of
extra revenue from the fact that
inflation has been high at the moment
that has brought in more taxes but he
didn't spend all of it and i think
that's the big question derma is whether
he comes back
uh and tries to spend that later on okay
i'm gonna come back to you and you can
put some uh numbers on that when you get
the spanner out and
fix your screen there let's talk to sam
while you do that and um
sam as we're hearing there because of
inflation real incomes
are falling that is a real political
problem for any party
that's right and you've got to look at
the two big choices that uh rishi sununu
made today the first was as ed was
saying not to spend all the money so
basically today there was a bill of
about 27 billion pounds for the measures
that he did things like uh raising the
personal allowance the amount that you
can uh receive before starting to pay
national insurance for that income tax
cut in
2024 by one pence and for the fuel duty
drop now
all of those things pretty much are
universal measures you'll benefit i'll
benefit from them they're not targeted
at the lowest uh paid
and the consequence of that is that
rishi sunak has spent quite a lot of
money today helping people arguably who
didn't uh entirely need uh to be helped
because i think the striking choice that
he made and it was a political choice
and it's a choice as far as i can tell
it's being endorsed by conservative mps
from all wings of the party is not to do
things like put more money into the
benefit system uh which uh universal
credit for instance people who are
part-time work or low-income or have
families um so you look at the various
groups that weren't particularly helped
today pensioners weren't particularly
given a handout by the chancellor people
on part-time work weren't particularly
helped people who don't have a job who
perhaps are unemployed can't get a job
for whatever reason uh those people
didn't get a particular help uh
particular assistance from the children
all those uh earning under nine thousand
uh maybe because they don't work uh uh
five days a week so those are the groups
that are were already gonna suffer the
most and won't have really benefited
from today okay let's go back to eddie's
now go to screen working and ed tell us
then you you mentioned that the
chancellor's keeping some of his powder
dry so to speak how much wiggle room has
he got with the money
yeah i don't know if it was obvious that
i was kind of scrambling beneath the
surface there this but now this doesn't
seem to be working uh i'll show you a
couple of things okay that go to that
point okay first of all
uh that just the squeeze that we're
facing at the moment is worth just kind
of reflecting on because i think it is
impossible to think about the state of
the economy at the moment without
thinking about
this bar here this this bar here the big
fall in disposable income uh that we are
facing in the next year you see that one
there that is the lowest
that we've ever seen that we've ever
seen since these records uh began in
fact i think you have to go back this
this starts in 1950s i think you
actually have to go back to the 1920s
the mid-1920s that was a terrible period
for the uk economy we rejoined the gold
standard it was disastrous wages fell
very very sharply so if that's what
we're about to go through
you know there was a big question mark
over
you know people are talking about
whether the chancellor has done enough
you know we are talking about a totemic
fall in people's living standards which
everyone will uh experience as for where
that money might come from well you know
if you look at kind of just a breakdown
of some of the money that kind of went
out of the treasury and some of the
money that came back in we you know a
certain amount did go out what we've got
here basically is showing this this bar
is kind of you know neutral that's zero
and then everything else there is money
going out a lot was spent on
national insurance so the threshold
going up um a decent amount was spent on
fuel duty 2.4 billion and then you had
that energy bills uh the support there
for energy bills uh that we saw that was
announced just a few months ago
but here's the thing there is more money
left to spend and why is that it's
because it's up to the chancellor as to
what fiscal rules he sets himself
and that's a determination that he can
make you know there's there's no rule
that says you've only got so much to
spend other than what you think is
possible and if that comes back to
something else
debt interest just how high are interest
rates and how comfortable is he with
them and again that's a question that no
one else could answer but himself
that interest is going to be really high
in the next year but as a percentage of
gdp it's not that high compared with
some periods in the 80s and it goes down
quite quickly so i think he will be
forced to come back and give more
answers about why he hasn't done more
why that bar's not going out even
further
given the historic scale of what we're
going through at the moment okay thanks
so sam how has that not doing more gone
down with some of his back benches i
mean on this national insurance rise yes
there's been some help in terms of
rising the threshold by three thousand
pounds but they wanted to see it
cancelled all together
um that's right but i wouldn't
jump to the conclusion that this evening
there is some kind of particularly big
grumble on the tory about benches about
today's plan think of it very very
cynically in terms of different groups
inside the conservative party there are
fans of boris johnson who just want
everything that this government does to
go well and they are cheering this mini
budget there are um opponents of uh
boris johnson who quite like rishi cena
now they also want the chancellor to do
well and they were cheering the budget
when i spoke to them earlier and there
were those on the one nation wing who
quite liked the pro-jobs policy as they
saw it there were some on the right who
liked the package that they saw it
because there was no
injection of cash into universal credit
so if you look around the tory party i
didn't find a great deal of dissent and
haven't seen uh any being reported
elsewhere but here's the thing
tonight the first polls have dropped and
they're not that good 66 percent of
people say that they uh
they think that they do that the spring
statement doesn't benefit people uh like
them much that's a poll from yougov
69 of britain so the spring statement
has not done enough to help with the
cost of living and and i bet you dermott
some of that is because frankly what
happened today was just plain weird
because last autumn rishi seneca
announced that he was going to do a
great big tax rise using national
insurance and then today he clawed back
some of that rise he sort of deadened
its impact and essentially cut the
amount of money he was going to get from
that rise by tweaking the the allowance
uh that you can raise before you start
to pay it so he's giving with one hand
taking away with the other i think a lot
of people are just looking at going
what
sam coat said conway thank you both very
much indeed well i want to speak now to
someone who uh worked very closely with
the chancellor when it comes to the
decisions made and announced in the
spring statement i'm joined by john
glenn mp city minister and economic
secretary to the treasury uh very good
evening to you mr glenn and let me put
that very point to you then why didn't
the chancellor do even more given it
seems he had some wriggle room with the
finances
well i recognize that wriggle room that
he's left and it's
directly because of the uncertainty and
the obr also was very explicit
in saying that the uncertainty means
that that could be wiped out very easily
and given that uncertainty and given as
ed just explained that we're spending 83
billion pounds that's 1200 pounds for
every man woman and child in this
country on debt interest payments it's
nearly four times what we spent last
year we have clearly got to be very
careful about the fundamentals of our
public finances
and the fact is as the chancellor said
in the house of commons it seems a lot
of it is beyond our control i mean this
is a chilling statement isn't it that we
should be prepared
for the economy and the public finances
to worsen potentially
significantly how worried are you that
we could be facing stagflation
stuttering falling growth and rising
inflation well it's not a question of
worrying it's a question of dealing with
the situation as we see it and we see a
degree of uncertainty and we have to
actually respond to that and what the
chancellor's done today and i think
you've been through some of the changes
that he's announced we've made some
significant changes to the thresholds by
which people pay tax we've helped people
by reducing fuel duty something that
hasn't happened for many many years but
i recognize that you know this isn't
going to solve everyone's every
household's challenges over the coming
months but what the chancellor also did
in february is is brought forward 350
pounds for every household he
particularly goes with in band a to d
uh in a couple of weeks they'll receive
150 pounds rebate on their council tax
to assist with the the cost of
of heating their homes but these are
extremely challenging times and the
chancellor as ever has a balancing act
and he's also set very clearly what he
wants to do with the future of the
economy creating the conditions for
growth investing and encouraging
businesses to invest in capital in their
human capital and in ideas so that the
economy can grow
and be in the best place to to grow well
out of these the uncertainty that we see
at the moment okay
all right i mean just to get on to some
of the more specific measures um you
know some of the emissions and it's been
pointed out you know why weren't the
most vulnerable in society helped those
on benefits those out of work those
working part-time people who don't have
cars they've been left out
well of course one of the big things
that we did uh following on not only
from the the fuel duty cut and the
household the
measures to help people with their fuel
bills that i just mentioned we've also
doubled the household support money to a
billion pounds and that will be money
that will go through local authorities
and over the last two years the
chancellor has put a number of
interventions through the covid crisis
and worked with local authorities who've
given those discretionary grants and
formal grants out to local businesses
and individuals and so we're relying on
that as a mechanism to help
support some of the most vulnerable in
our community i mean it it sounds like a
lot of money a billion pounds in that
household support fund um but it's it's
a one-off payment isn't it and you have
to apply through your local authority i
mean why not just increase universal
credit give it to everyone
well we believe that local authorities
have played a phenomenal role over the
last couple of years and we're just
building on that experience as i said we
used them to dispense
grants to businesses some of which were
very clearly set out from from whitehall
others were discretionary because we
recognized that councils councillors up
and down the country have a role to play
in supporting their local communities
and we're providing the means for them
to continue to do that but i wouldn't
want to hide from the fact that you know
having spent 400 billion pounds having
now to spend 1200 pounds for every man
woman and child
up and down the country next year in
debt interest payments these are very
uncomfortable times and obviously today
we saw the growth forecast reduced to
3.8 percent um and we saw inflation at
6.2 percent we haven't seen that for for
a very long time as ed pointed out on
the graph earlier and these are very
uncomfortable times for the economy what
we've done today what the chancellor's
done today is put in some significant
interventions that will help a lot of
people 30 million people will have over
300 pounds more in the summer what about
um the windfall tax suggested by labor
on and others
on energy companies who are making an
awful lot of money about the the rising
energy prices surely that meant would
have meant you could have done even more
why didn't you do it well there's two
things i'd say there one is that these
firms already
taxed much higher than other firms and
secondly we want to create the
conditions for them to invest and i
welcome bp's decision today to
signal they're going to invest a billion
pounds in in charging
infrastructure but we do need to
encourage the dividends to their
shareholders well well what we also what
we need is we need to realize that if
we're going to have a growing economy we
need businesses to invest in growth and
setting those conditions for growth is
critically important what we've also
done is help smaller businesses uh by
removing uh some more of the costs that
they have to pay in terms of national
insurance contributions by increasing
the the allowance there so that's
another thousand pounds that they will
be saved from paying so you know we've
made a range of interventions but the
reason we happen to answer your question
specifically is because we don't want to
act as a disincentive to investment
which is important as we need to grow
the economy and just this uh badge
you're going to wear into the next uh
election a conservative party overseeing
a a fall in real disposable incomes and
the highest tax burden for 77 years it's
uh not a badge of pride is it
well no i don't think anyone anticipated
when we won the general election two and
a half years ago that we would go
through covet and spend 400 billion i
don't think we could have anticipated
fully the extent of the crisis in the
ukraine what we've got to do is keep
calm work through the issues and make
decisions at each physical event in the
interest of the british people and
that's what the chancellor has done
today
john glenn very good talking to you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us on sky news tonight
and that's it for our special program on
the chancellor's spring statement coming
up next on sky news tonight the latest
on the war in ukraine as we await the
arrival of air force one and president
biden back in europe
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now joe biden is due to land in europe
any moment now before key summits of
nato and g7 leaders tomorrow the aim of
the meetings to coordinate joint action
on europe's energy security and respond
to continuing russian aggression the
president is also expected to announce
extra sanctions against russia when he
arrives in brussels our u.s
correspondent mark stone reports from
brussels
as the american president left the white
house for europe there was a stark
answer for one of so many troubling
questions
[Music]
how high is that threat
i think it's a real threat
given the stakes given the bloodshed
perhaps it's a surprise that the
american president has taken this long
to travel to europe to face the russian
threat ahead of him now are three
summits nato the eu and the g7 back to
back in one day it is an unprecedented
reflection on the current state of peace
and stability in europe
and here it is spelt out by
propagandists pundits connected to the
kremlin on russian state tv european
hollow threats designed to spook to
create leverage the thing is who can be
sure right now
the leaders of the 30 nato member
countries will be forced to confront
this extraordinary reality when they
meet here in brussels in the hours ahead
the headline will be a remarkable
doubling of the number of nato troops
deployed to eastern europe an
unavoidable reaction to a russian
aggression that is so unpredictable but
how will president putin react is it
perhaps perilously provocative
the alliance's secretary general whose
tenure may now be extended to provide
continuity could not clearly answer the
biggest questions how does nato defend
itself against a nuclear attack thank
you
russia must stop its
nuclear saber rattling
this is dangerous and it is
irresponsible
for now the russian attacks on ukraine
remain conventional but devastating
nonetheless these missiles in footage
issued by the russian military
apparently hit ukrainian military
targets sky news is unable to verify the
claim
russia's foreign minister was preempting
nato announcements and on a suggestion
from poland that it could send a
peacekeeping force to ukraine he had
this
i hope they know what they are talking
about
this will be that very confrontation
between russian and nato armed forces
that everyone not just wanted to avoid
but said that it should never happen to
begin with
his master president putin told
officials that russia would continue to
supply europe with energy but would
charge in rubles
and undermine the dollar
there will be pressure at the eu summit
on nations like germany to cut loose
from russian energy but that is so much
easier said than done
so many challenges so many frightening
scenarios and a blunt reality that
nothing the west has done so far has
ended putin's war
mark stone joins me now live from
brussels so mark uh the president uh
aiming to maintain unity and turn the
screw further on russia
yeah and you know dermot i suppose on
reflection
isn't it a bit of a surprise that it's
taken the american president this long
to come to europe uh given the stakes
given the bloodshed in ukraine uh it has
taken quite some time for a decision to
be made that he would come here that he
would be here in person for this not not
just one summit as i say but a trio of
summits it's worth pointing out that
that he has been pushing for these
summits to take place there was a
suggestion not all that long ago that
maybe there wouldn't be a nato summit
well there is they're having it um and
as i say alongside that eu leaders will
meet uh president biden will be will
join eu leaders at their meeting here in
the in the center of brussels
uh and separately there will be a g7
meeting as well and uh the um the
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
has just arrived in the european
commission headquarters uh to meet us
lavonda lyon the the president of the
commission uh for meetings tonight ahead
of those those big meetings tomorrow
we're just awaiting the u.s president's
arrival uh at zaventem airport um not
far from the center of brussels here uh
where he has um where he will um travel
from there uh to the american embassy
and tomorrow he will be a central part
of such high-stakes diplomatic
discussion okay mark thank you very much
indeed uh you're watching sky news
tonight uh coming up we'll have the very
latest as mark was describing there on
the president's visit to europe and also
the chancellor's spring statement
[Music]
so
[Music]
you